tony robbins tony rocco and what [ __ ] i
love it dude did you like it i thought
it was corny why it didn't fight me [ __ ]
like just be funny
no
in real life though well actually [ __ ]
people at a show on the left factory not
like not the actual fight but somebody
was upset by some crowd work he was
doing yeah and he was like i'll see you
later and then tony rob goes you ain't
gonna do [ __ ] right there and then he
goes you know why you're gonna do [ __ ]
because this whole top row was with me
and then just pointed all those top face
homies in the top row yeah and i was
like oh he keeps that same energy yeah
that guy always talks [ __ ] he don't care
and then the funniest part is i got
nothing to lose that's what i thought
was really only like the fame gap yeah
that's funny i don't know i just like
i don't know just be funny about there's
so much room for jokes like i don't even
know if you got to threaten these
[ __ ] it's different because
that's family yeah you know so obviously
maybe it's different i would react that
way but um i really want to see what
rock got to say about it well apparently
he got a standing ovation the next time
he went on stage yeah but he didn't say
nothing somebody said [ __ ] chris rock or
[ __ ] will smith and then he silenced
them he was like no we don't need that
yeah they started a [ __ ] will smith
chant during the show oh there you go
people hate will right now
i mean it is crazy like there's nobody i
feel like initially like day one is
people on wheels side
you still see a few huh you still see a
few but yeah it definitely has gone
women and guys that cheat on their girl
yeah yeah yeah yeah those are the only
people who support this only i get to
disrespect my wife
you got to protect all these dudes you
got to protect your woman you [ __ ] other
women yeah 100 percent guarantee you're
over compensating because you're you're
the jada in your relationship any guy
that's faithful loves the fact that his
wife got uh pissed off in public
why cause you can't do it
[Laughter]
do you know what i mean like i i l dude
i like this happened uh this weekend i
was in the [ __ ] bahamas and uh yeah
how was it uh it was it was actually
really nice but we're in the bahamas and
like um i like realize how my like
relationship is evolving a little bit
like
my i was at a casino and i'm playing
blackjack and i see my wife try to cross
through the blackjack pit
okay you know nobody was there so she
tries to walk behind the table basically
to walk through right and
she tries to cut through and then the
the the casino like the pit boss walks
over and he's like he's like miss you
can't cross through now she got about
halfway through okay and i'm looking at
my wife
and she doesn't immediately turn around
and i'm and i'm like i know exactly what
this business is
i know exactly she's going to say i'm
already halfway through why not just go
all the other half yeah yeah right you
would never do such a thing no
that's why we're married
i 100 would do the same thing like it's
the same way why are you gonna make me
walk that but the pit guy his job is to
keep people out of the [ __ ] pit right
so i see my wife go but i'm already half
it's the same distance just to go the
other half want to just go the other
half and the guy goes
i don't care get out of the pit and i
literally went you tell her
tell her what to do because you don't
have to worry about [ __ ] she's already
going to not [ __ ] you
dude i mean she can't give you the cold
shoulder key she can't do none of that
[ __ ] so i was rooting for that
[ __ ] anybody who could tell my
wife what to do without repercussions
yeah you're on their team
i tipped him
i gave him 25 i flicked a quarter of
them yeah my wife are you really on his
side yeah
yeah
i need a higher security for my white
phil
i need a higher security to discipline
my wife
because i can't discipline my wife
that's what i need that's you bro yeah
no no no no
i like being here
[Laughter]
i don't know why we even talk about oh
yeah so like yeah i guess will just
can't admit that
yeah right and now he's taking off all
his projects they're like halted bad
boys
they like apparently
was they like changed madagascar [ __ ]
because jada was in the movie or
something what was she
[Laughter]
yeah come on i need black women to
support me dude yeah
that's fine they can all support you
except jada that's true also isn't jada
half white
no half uh
pool cue
was that what i meant it was pool queue
right
that's what i meant to say yeah
wait is the queue the ball yeah okay
good oh
i thought it might be the stick no the
queue is the stick with the cue ball
oh what y'all knew what the [ __ ]
even though i didn't get the word right
okay now she's half black half witch oh
my god sorceress damn bro sorceress this
guy's serious dude yeah do you believe
in sorcery and uh in uh hinduism
i do now
after seeing jada but is it part of the
religion no 100 percent not no okay but
there's no like
like devil
demon [ __ ] no no no you just get
reincarnated you just keep going really
there's no hell so what's the [ __ ] with
the little snake coming out there little
thing dude oh yeah the magic power bruh
it's just power that's power that's
sorcery power now but you got that in
you you know what i mean you just don't
do it because you're a little [ __ ]
we also don't have snakes yeah yeah we
also live in the first world yeah
that's a great place to be the first
world gay
yeah it was crazy to see what happened
with the whole whale [ __ ] man i i wonder
what he's going through now he has
another netflix project that they put on
policies oh they really just pause
everything he's done you know i'm not
done but he's like they're like yo you
can't do anything right now jesus dude
if you thought you if you thought people
[ __ ] your wife
now
imagine when you can't even provide for
her oh my god dawg yeah when you're a
d-less actor oh she's gonna be getting
the d-list
that's what's gonna be happening
i don't know if we talked about this but
like if he just came out and he just
said
did we discuss this on this podcast
it it's hard how could you possibly
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
you know what's funny is the only way he
gets his back really is if he divorces
her so again if he divorced her we'd all
be like oh this guy's out of there god
bless him give him his movies back oh
yeah 100
divorce her and blame her for everything
yeah yeah even though you're a loser and
you're not you know being personally
accountable just [ __ ] blame her dude
just [ __ ] we want will back it's
correct dude i mean he drops another
independence day and it's like you know
double meaning
a new album i love it he's gotta drop
like what's what's like uh the lemonade
for guys
i don't know if we have one but like you
know beyonce dropped lemonade remember
when she was gonna leave jay-z well the
name of the movie that's in
post-production that netflix
would like to release it's anton fuca
directing it's called emancipation no
that's hilarious emancipation what is it
about your name about like a famous uh
uh slave that have you seen that picture
the one with all the scars on his back
bro you know what's crazy is that this
is where will's career is now
will never even play black guys wow yeah
isn't that interesting he just played
leading man
and now he's playing
a slave bro
yeah son [ __ ] son he's playing django
too
and it's not even django too how [ __ ]
sad is that yeah
nobody cares anymore yo that's [ __ ] up
dude al can you weigh in on this so we
don't feel racist
yeah i'm actually having pressure on you
mom's gonna be on board antoine training
day legendary director i'm on board i
feel bad for will though say again i
just feel bad for will because he's one
of my heroes and it's just like damn
yeah yeah see this decline it's like it
sucks